well I'm really here to do today is talk
to you about micromanagement and what I
learn about micromanagement by being a
micro manager over the last few years of
my life but first off what is
micromanagement
how do we how do we really define it
well I posit that it's actually taking
great wonderful imaginative people like
all of you bringing them in into an
organization and then crushing their
souls by telling them what font size to
use you know and so in the history of
mankind has anyone ever said this John
we were never gonna close that deal with
Times New Roman but because you insisted
on how petaca BAM dotted line millions
of dollars start to flow that was a
missing piece no one's ever said that
right there's actually physical
manifestations that we probably see in
ourselves by being micromanage
think about some of the most tired
you've ever been in your life right it
probably wasn't when you stayed the
latest at work or it wasn't when you
came home from a road trip it was
probably when you had someone looking
over your shoulder watching your each
and every move
kind of like my mother-in-law when she's
over right so you know I'm like I got
this you know and so there's actually
data to support this so there was a
recent study in the UK they took a
hundred Hospital employees put an
activity tracker on them and then let
them go about their next 12-hour shift
all alone just a regular 12-hour shift
at the end of the shift they asked them
do you feel fatigued and what they found
was actually really interesting so it
wasn't necessarily the people who moved
the most that felt the most fatigue but
it was the folks that didn't have
control over their jobs so we know that
micromanagement isn't really effective
why do we do it so is it that the
definition is wrong so I posited that
you know micromanagement is just
bringing in great wonderful imaginative
people and then crushing their souls so
is it that we actually want to hire deep
down inside of us dull and unimaginative
people I don't know it's one of those
questions you probably don't even need
to ask right it's like do you want to
get your luggage stolen at the airport
like probably not but I've never been
asked right so as anyone have asked you
as a manager like do you want to hire
dull and unimaginable so I don't know
this is Ted we better back it up with
data so we actually asked hundreds of
people around the country hundreds of
managers across the country do you want
to hire dull and unimaginative people
all right it's an interesting question
well interesting results as well so 94%
said no we don't want to hire dull and
unimaginable right
six percent probably didn't understand
the question but but bless their hearts
maybe they do just want to hire Tull and
I'd imagine people but ninety-four
percent said they did not and so why do
we do this Phil then well I posit that
it's something really really simple that
all of us deep down inside know and I've
actually felt so when we get hired into
an organization it could be a club it
could be a law firm it could be a school
organization it could be anything
no one ever jumps to the top of the
totem pole right you start at the very
bottom doing what doing work you
actually do the work right and if you're
really good at doing the work what do
you get rewarded with more work right
and so yeah that's right you know you
guys are all great micro managers so you
do more work and then pretty soon if
you're really good at it you do a little
bit of work still but actually you start
to manage people doing the work and if
you're really good at that what happens
after that you start managing the people
who manage the people doing the work and
it's at that point in time you start to
lose control over the output of your job
I've actually witnessed this firsthand
so I started a company called box our
garage and this was it I know it doesn't
seem like much you know but but it was
you know his pressure washing their back
this is living the dream and you know my
wife was really proud of me when we
started this or it's what she said you
know she was really proud of me and so
she would give me a hug I'm pretty sure
like she had her phone up and she was
thinking oh is John from Harvard still
single you know it's kind of like a
lemonade stand gone wrong in the
beginning but we actually went up and
you know said mobile commerce is gonna
be big and actually consumer packaged
goods we're gonna change over time so
let's take these big bulky packs that
you don't want to look home so not that
2-pack of Oreo cookies but the 20
or pack and not the 24 pack of toilet
paper but the 48 pack and let's ship it
to you much like a warehouse club would
do except they wouldn't ship it to you
and so that's what we basically did and
so we had a really slow printer and what
we did was actually say okay this
printer is taking forever man like okay
let's scribble something that would
delight the customer on the back of
these invoices so we'd say hey you know
keep smiling you know hey you know like
you're awesome or hey enjoy the Doritos
or you know we love Gatorade to stuff
like that and so it started breaking up
the monotony of the job as well because
I was picking and packing all the boxes
and that's all you basically do for
eight nine ten twelve hours a day when
you're sitting in the garage and so an
interesting thing happened so we
actually started to grow and so you know
over the last actually just even thirty
six months after that we ended up
selling hundreds of millions of dollars
worth of stuff and we actually grew
really really quickly but during that
time my role started to change too so
yes I was a CEO in the garage that was
picking and packing doing all the work
but then I actually graduated to
actually you know managing the people
who picked impact and then pretty soon I
managed the people who manage the people
picking and packing and even now I
managed to see staff who managed the
departments who managed the people who
manage the people picking and packing
and is at that point in time I lost
control so I thought okay we were
delighting all these customers with
these notes right they loved them but I
can't write these notes anymore so you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna tell
these folks how to write these notes and
so what pen to use what color to use
what you should write what font you
should use don't mess up the margins you
know this has to be this big this has to
be that big and pretty soon this goal of
raising morale by breaking up the
monotony in the fulfillment center
actually became micromanagement and
people started complaining to HR it's
like dude the CEO guy he's gotta get on
my hair okay I know how to write a damn
note okay so is that that point in time
we said okay you know we hire these
great wonderful people let's give them
the mission s delight the customer let's
give them the tool to do so and that's
these notes have at it and so what we
found was actually pretty startling so
some folks actually took the notes and
actually started drawing these really
ornate
like mini murals on them you know when
folks order diapers you'd get really fun
notes like this you know say hi to the
baby for us and you know the next size
up you know if you bought a bigger size
they'd write you know growing up so fast
and so people really really took to it
but it was at that time that it also
went off the rails a few times and so we
had someone just writing thx thx all the
time it's like alright dude you know
like my boss used to write that to me
and so let's not write thx anymore but
you also had interesting things on the
other side people got a little too
creative and so like I said before we
sell everything in bulk right the big
packs of diapers big packs of toilet
paper the big packs of Doritos and Oreo
cookies we also sell the big packs of
contraception and so hello Harry ha ha
so we sell the 40 pack of condoms right
we're all adults in this room you know
40 pack of condoms and so someone
ordered for 40 packs of condoms and
that's all they wrote or all they had
all they ordered so 160 condoms the
Packer was like I know how to delight
the customer you know like this you
don't like this guy this is you know
this is what they wrote
[Applause]
yeah we didn't know to fire him or to
promote him but he's still there so
everyone loves an optimist but here here
is when it went a little bit off the
rails and I felt a little bit conflicted
in all this and this oh there's a really
bad typo so if there was only a red TD
on stage I counted on being here it
wouldn't be a typo right I promised you
I had a really bad sense of humor and
now I've got to find that so I told you
but I really was conflicted right at
this point in time we started doing
things that actually weren't part of our
core mission and people started failing
at it and so I thought and it's should
we let them fail should we continue to
let them do this I don't know I I I
didn't know at that moment but I thought
this it's failure really that bad I mean
I'm not saying we should celebrate
failure there's a lot of talk in Silicon
Valley says let's celebrate failure no I
don't know if we're going you know our
board meetings like our board members
are never like hey yeah you failed last
quarter keep doing that buddy okay you
know like no one's ever said that if
you're part of an organization like that
give me a call I want to sit in on that
meeting and so in private I don't think
many people celebrate failure but
actually failure I posit is actually
pretty necessary for the folks truly in
the long term for the smart and imagine
of people truly trying to fulfill the
mission that you give them at hand and
so failure can actually be seen as a
milestone along that mission towards
success and if so the downside of not
micromanaging is potentially this
perceived notion that you might fail
more often and if it's really not that
bad what is the upside well we saw the
upside is pretty great so we tasked our
engineers and said hey you know our some
of our fulfillment centers cost millions
of dollars to build there's miles and
miles of conveyor and so can you do the
same thing can you make them efficient
without spending millions of dollars so
they got to work they actually did this
you know it's not Photoshop the guys
like really grinding and it's like they
built an autonomous guided vehicle we
didn't tell them what to build what
format it needed to be in 90 days they
produced the first prototype powered off
Tesla battery stereoscopic cameras lidar
systems it
basically replicates the efficiency of a
conveyor belt without the actual capex
of a conveyor belt so it doesn't
actually just stop with engineers our
marketing team barmen we told them hey
you know get the word out do the right
thing so we have this wonderful lady by
the name of Natasha on the marketing
team she stopped me in the morning she's
like Jay what are we doing about the
pink tax
I went got my coffee and says I sat down
I said okay Natasha what is this pink
tax and so she told me it's really
interesting so someone you might know
that actually in 32 states across
America we actually charge a luxury good
tax on women's products like feminine
care products so tampons and pads are
tax like luxury good items so I would
never dare call my wife or if she called
me and said hey hon bring some pads on
the way home and I said babe you know
just a trade war going on the economy's
not that good so you know no luxury
goods this month but next month I
promise you know I'll take a look at it
you know I've been single pretty quickly
right but what's what's super
interesting is now we didn't tell them
what to do but now working with finance
they rebate the tax back to customers
all around the country that we unfairly
have to collect and so at this point in
time you might be thinking okay what is
the real real upside of not
micromanaging and it's this I didn't do
any of these projects I didn't make the
AGV I didn't do the paint rethink to
paint tax campaign I don't do any of
this but I'm standing here on a TED
stage taking all the credit for it yeah
you know like this guy does nothing it
takes all the credit for it he's a real
CEO this guy's really got it down you
know but the reality is this I don't
have the CEO thing down 100% pat but
I've actually learned the most
fundamentally challenging lesson I've
ever had to learn and that's this there
is only one solution to micromanagement
and that's to trust thank you
[Applause]
[Music]